[Musique]
tous ces gens sont morts il y en a
beaucoup plus que ça sans tous ces gens
qui sont sur ce mur sont morts
prématurément à cause de leur addiction
oui il habitait tout ça creuse on ne
peut tout simplement pas sortir de cette
épidémie de toxicomanie le seul moyen
d'éradiquer le problème et l'éducation
la prévention pour éviter que les
enfants s'y mettent
nous avons vu les gens suivre des
programmes 10 ou 12 fois suivre un
traitement et ne jamais y arriver et
finir par en mourir ted massa ancien
toxicomane dirige aujourd'hui l'un des
centres de réinsertion privé d'akron
dans l'ohio tous essayé de se battre
même aux gars et sur la photo ici
il était surveillant au centre de
traitement nouveau destin il a été
retrouvé mort comme ça dans cette
position un autre gars a été retrouvé
avec sa petite amie dans leur
appartement qu'il venait d'obtenir
blottis l'un contre l'autre
ils sont restés comme ça pendant trois
jours en lacets
[Musique]
la population d'akron est d'environ
200000 personnes
il ya cent ans c'était l'une des villes
les plus dynamiques des états unis elle
était célèbre pour sa production de
caoutchouc et de pneus akron était même
considérée comme la capitale mondiale du
caoutchouc au cours des 50 dernières
années
sa population a diminué d'un tiers et
elle continue de diminuer
de nos jours à crown est connue comme la
capitale de la méthamphétamine de l'ohio
c'est une ville où le nombre de
toxicomanes continue d'augmenter chaque
année
ce film a été tourné dans plusieurs
centres privés de réinsertion
nous sommes au centre de réinsertion
emma la maison appartient à ma famille
depuis plus de 50 ans 53 ans je crois je
viens de lire quelques articles
on dit que le pire est déjà passé mais
c'est loin d'être le cas
les statistiques sont décourageantes on
vient de publier un rapport sur le comté
et on voit que nous allons dépasser de
beaucoup le taux de mortalité de l'année
dernière rena pa card loue des chambres
à d'anciens prisonniers et patients du
centre de réinsertion publics aux
personnes qui ont besoin d'un abri
temporaire sur ils peuvent y rester
gratuitement jusqu'à ce qu'ils se
trouvent un travail
après cela le loyer de 500 dollars par
mois
je m'appelle call ça fait dix mois que
j'ai commencé que je sois en vie est
incroyable
la dernière fois que j'ai consommé
alcool et drogue j'ai sauté par la
fenêtre de mon appartement du 4e étage
sur le trottoir je ne devrais pas être
en vie ici aujourd'hui je ne devrait pas
pouvoir marcher le principe même de la
réinsertion c'est de faire des petits
pas vous savez les choses ont tendance à
s'arranger
je m'appelle dan mois de janvier j'ai
contracté une infection en défonçant
mais j'ai dû me faire opérer du dos les
médecins m'ont dit que si j'avais
attendu un jour ou deux j'aurai fini par
réaliser aux morts je suis content de
m'être rétabli et reconnaissant d'être
encore en vie
la dernière fois ici je fumer un bang en
préparant une sorte de drogue dans la
cuisine je suis reconnaissant à reinach
de m'avoir donné une deuxième chance
comme léa et cory se sont rencontrés
alors qu'ils louaient tous les deux des
chambres chez reynaers ils ont été accro
à l'héroïne et à la mecque pendant plus
de dix ans cory est originaire d'une
famille très pauvre de virginie
occidentale
la mère de léa l'avait abandonné juste
après sa naissance et elle n'a jamais vu
son père biologique
[Musique]
ce bébé c'est moi c'était juste après
qu'il met adopté j'ai été adopté à
quatre jours j'ai rencontré ma mère
biologique
mais elle ne sait même pas qui est mon
père alors c'est un grand mystère
je m'en fout vraiment c'est pas
important
j'ai une très bonne famille de toute
façon donc
et voilà une photo où je suis déjà plus
grande j'avais 17 ans et demi j'étais
blonde
selon les à ses parents adoptifs étaient
des gens riches et affectueux mais cela
ne l'a pas empêché de plonger dans la
drogue est d'avoir un casier judiciaire
impressionnant
l'airé et corinne ne touche plus à la
drogue depuis plus d'un an
j'ai été brisées tout a commencé quand
on m'a violée à l'université dans des
escaliers
c'est là que j'ai commencé à boire et
c'est comme ça que j'ai plongé
mais à l'époque ce n'était pas permanent
avant que je passe à l'héroïne que
j'adorais elle me faisait oublier toutes
mes blessures
quand nous avons rencontré robe rawlings
il travaillait dans l'un des centres
d'akron et ne consommait pas de drogue
depuis un an et demi en plus de diverses
tâches organisationnelles dans le centre
ils allés à la rencontre de toxicomanes
dans la rue dans l'espoir de les aider à
changer de vie
au fond et j'espère que je pourrai
parler à ce jeune homme est planté cette
graine c'est l'essentiel
tout ce qu'il faut c'est qu'une personne
trouve une approche pour une autre
personne pour que la personne puisse à
nouveau croire en elle même quoi de neuf
doc on sait déjà rencontré tuer le
cousin de john-john ton visage mais
familiers mon oncle race et ça je
m'appelle robe jacou était donc pour toi
katie white et ma mère d'accord samedi
quelque chose les chercheurs sont
arrivés à la conclusion que nous avons
des marqueurs génétiques pour les
addictions il ya une prédisposition à
l'addiction
mais c'est aussi un comportement qu'on
développe si on a trois générations de
personnes sous le même toit qui sont
accros c'est déjà une pathologie
c'est difficile de s'en sortir comment
peut-on interrompre ce cycle si la
grand-mère et sous médocs le père sous
hallucinogènes et les enfants sont accro
à la méthamphétamine
par quoi commencer pour démêler tout ça
j'y suis presque mec je ne veux pas
finir comme un chiffre dans les
statistiques je veux donner quelque
chose à mon enfant que je n'ai pas eu
j'ai passé toute ma vie dans des
familles d'accueil mon père était
toujours fauché ma mère se droguait mes
oncles et tantes
je suis arrivé ici à 14 ans je suis
arrivé dans l'ohio est tous dans ma
famille était toxicomane il ya une
combinaison de facteurs dont nous sommes
toujours en train de gérer les
conséquences traumatiques dans les
années 90 et même plus tard les médecins
étaient encouragés et dans certains cas
inciter à prescrire trop de médicaments
dans des villes des petites villes qui
nous entourent ici dans l'ohio
des millions de cachets était prescrit
des quantités suffisantes pour mettre
sous calmant un petit pays
il ya aussi les cartels de sinaloa et
les autres cartels mexicains qui ont des
centres de distribution dans toute la
rue ste belt et le midwest l'ohio a été
un point central la toxicomanie et les
nombreux décès par overdose sont les
principales causes de la réduction
permanente de la population de l'ohio
selon le journal de l'association
médicale américaine en l'espace de sept
ans de 2010 à 2017
le taux de mortalité chez les personnes
de 25 à 64 ans a augmenté de plus de 20%
oui ce mémorial a été conçu et construit
par nos jeunes résidents ceux qui vivent
au centre c'est une partie de nous une
partie de ce qu'on fait c'est d'ajouter
un peu de structure dans la vie de ces
jeunes
la cérémonie de la mort a eu lieu pour
la première fois en 2013
quand nous avons enterré ici le premier
jeune homme du centre et ça n'était que
le début
ils partent l'un après l'autre ce sont
donc les symboles de ces jeunes âmes qui
sont venus chez nous qui ont demandé de
l'aide et ce ne seront pas les derniers
[Applaudissements]
il ya eu quelques membres de notre
équipe qui ont vécu à la maison quand
ils ont quitté le centre
en dépit de nos conseils quarante huit
heures plus tard il était mort la
rechute leur coeur se sont arrêtés c'est
ça le problème des rechutes
si vous êtes en cure de désintoxication
votre niveau de tolérance est bien plus
bas alors que quand vous repartez
beaucoup de choses ont déjà changé dans
la rue il s'agit d'un produit chimique
qui peut provoquer un arrêt cardiaque
avec la masse net d'un grain de sel les
produits chimiques qui évoque reinhardt
sont le fentanyl et le quart fentanyl ce
sont des opioïdes utilisé comme
analgésique
ces substances sont assez similaires à
l'héroïne mais beaucoup plus puissante
le quart fentanyl est 100 fois plus
puissant que le fentanyl et cinq mille
fois plus puissant que l'héroïne le
quart fentanyl est si fort qu'on
l'utilisent comme tranquillisants pour
les éléphants 2 mg de cette substance
suffisent tu as sommer un éléphant ces
dernières années il ya eu un grand
nombre d'overdoses à cause du fentanyl
et du quart fontanil ce sont des drogues
bon marché et les dealers les mélanges
avec de l'héroïne et de la mecque qui
coûte plus cher pour gagner plus
d'argent et renforcer la diction de
leurs clients pour les dealers il est
très difficile de bien doser lorsqu'ils
préparent le mélange chez eux beaucoup
de personnes meurent d'overdose et ceux
qui survivent subissent un sevrage lourd
qui est encore plus douloureux que celui
de l'héroïne
si on en fait trop on touche le fond
je me demande toujours pourquoi
voudrait-on tuer sa clientèle mais quand
j'entendais que des gens mouraient
disons comme ray ray quelqu'un trois
personnes en sont mortes
oh ça doit être de la bonne il faut il
en trouver le type n'était qu'un fou il
en a trop fait il ne savait pas ce qu'il
faisait
je ne suis pas comme lui je suis rom
rawlings chaque dog et nous n'allons pas
finir de la même manière faut qu'on
entend une vie bam
tout s'est fini c'est fini on touche le
fond nous sommes dans la maison il n'y a
personne autour de nous et devinez quoi
c'est fini c'est simple mec oui c'est
exactement comme ça
on veut un peu parfait mais akron le
trafic de drogue est depuis longtemps
devenue une source de revenus simple et
accessible
si quelqu'un essaye d'arrêter et de
sortir de l'addiction
il se heurte à l'omniprésence des
dealers c'est facile une fois j'ai
emménagé dans un centre et je ne voulais
pas encore vraiment arrêter mais je
pensais que c'était fait j'allais
prendre un bus depuis le centre c'était
sur browse street un super quartier et
j'ai rencontré mon dealer qui se
dirigeait vers l'arrêt de bus il m'a
demandé et tu veux essayer
c'était aussi simple que ça et j'ai
répondu bien sûr
j'ai répondu qu'est ce que tu as sur toi
mon pote c'est comme ça que j'ai fait
l'une de mes rechute une autre
conséquence de cette épidémie
c'est l'explosion proportionnelle de la
criminalité je viens justement de lire
que trois jeunes hommes ont été abattus
ici dans la rue dans une fusillade
il s'agit pourtant d'une petite ville
dont la population est de 190 mille
personnes et nous avons des fusillades
comme à chicago dans les années 30 voyez
c'est une vague de criminalité
des tirs ont frappé le bâtiment voisin
des balles de 9 mm ont sont passés à
travers les fenêtres
c'est comme à l'époque du far west et
tout ça à cause de cette épidémie
[Musique]
d'accord on va mettre ça et c'est au
michel je ne suis pas une mère d'accord
ok là ne sont près de l'église accro à
bron street et nous sont venus ici pour
faire la fête
ici les enfants vont de porte à porte de
voiture un voiture avec leurs costumes
et demande et friandises c'est bientôt
halloween et c'est une église et voilà
ce qu'ont fait la majeure partie de ceux
qui sont ici se remettre d'une addiction
et c'est un quartier difficile
alexa cole dhruv membres de l'église
d'akron à quatre enfants elle n'est pas
mariée elle a cessé de prendre de la met
il ya plus d'un an
alexa pense que c'est addiction au sexe
et à la drogue trouvent leurs racines
dans son enfance
mon père m'a appris à boxer il m'a élevé
comme si j'étais son fils est pas sa
fille
c'est comme ça que je m'habillais
beaucoup de gens se moquaient de moi à
cause de cela et puis mon père prenait
parti pour ma belle mère est pas pour
moi je savais qu'elle ne m'aimait pas et
qu'elle n'appréciait pas la relation que
nous avions avec mon père ils volent et
lui plaire et donc je me retrouvais tout
seul je pense que c'est là que tout a
commencé
je voulais simplement coucher avec
quelqu'un que ce soit pour une nuit cinq
minutes passer une heure où quelques
heures avec quelqu'un cela me donnait le
sentiment de valloire encore quelque
chose
les drogues chasser la douleur mais plus
je couchais avec des gens ou plus il y
avait des gens à qui j'avais fait du mal
puis il me fallait de drogue pour
chasser ses sentiments
c'était un chemin qui ne menaient nulle
part et en fin de compte je me suis
retrouvé au point où plus rien ne
marchait ici je joue au baseball
ouais j'ai été très bon à 14 ans je
jouais dans la little league world
series j'étais très fort le baseball est
un moyen de m'évader mon échappatoire de
cette enfance c'était ma force motrice
pendant les moments difficiles je viens
encore ici c'est ma zone de sécurité si
vous voulez marchait bien on est plus
lourd j'aime être avec les enfants
j'aime aider les enfants je ne veux pas
dire que j'utilise parfois mes amis pour
voir leurs enfants mais je passe du
temps avec eux parce qu'être entouré
d'enfants me permet de me détendre
non je n'étais pas là pour mes enfants
ma mère a fait de son mieux fait pas la
timide hausse est bon le lait au
chocolat n'est ce pas mon père était
très violent physiquement et mentalement
même si l'oea ne connaît pas son père
biologique
elle se dit extrêmement reconnaissant
envers son père adoptif
il a continué à croire en elle pendant
toutes ces années d'addiction
et c'est en grande partie grâce à ce
soutien qu'elle a réussi à surmonter son
problème à fonder une famille avec cory
et a acheté une maison dans un bon
quartier
j'ai perdu tant de vêtements les jours
où j'étais accro où pendant mes rechute
mon pauvre père chaque fois que j'étais
en traitement il était obligé de m'en
acheter de nouveaux vêtements
il était tellement bon pour aller au
magasin et choisir des vêtements pour
femmes que les vendeuses du magasin le
reconnaissait elle disait a encore
besoin de nouveaux vêtements
[Musique]
mon père a choisi ce quartier pour nous
il s'est dit que ce serait un bon
endroit pour fonder une famille oui ça
se perd on ne serait pas là non là c'est
ce qui compte
le soutien de la famille des habits pour
le bébé encore plus d'habits pour le bbc
pour aulas couverture maintien nous
sommes presque prêt nous faisons ce que
nous pouvons
ce sont mes poupées ragués dix années
andy je les ai depuis ma plus tendre
enfance ma mère les a achetés ce sont
des objets rares maintenant je suppose
mon père les a gardés pendant toutes ces
années et les a données à notre lit dit
nous sommes au cimetière mount pis dans
le quartier de times square à akron ohio
nous venons ici tous les matins pour que
pai façon à faire mais aussi pour rendre
visite à notre groupe de marginaux ils
sont nombreux ici
ferry croyante point fr par exemple tom
avec 36 ans
en fait c'était l'un des tout premiers
bénévoles et membres du personnel de
l'institut un exprès extrêmement
créative quelqu'un de très beau aussi il
avait l'air d'un viking
il n'avait que 36 ans
la veille de sa mort il avait préparé sa
spécialité le dessert qu'il faisait pour
la maison d or et aux à la crème glacée
nous avons fait la fête et le lendemain
il est mort
[Musique]
cet apple avait également loué une
chambre chez reinhardt pour se remettre
de ses addictions
il avait été adopté par land c'est
carole apple
un couple chrétien pieux aisés qui
semblait prospérer dans tous les sens du
terme et 18 jours sont passés depuis que
notre fils nous a quittés il est mort le
12 novembre
j'ai reçu l'appel à 8h36 du matin c'est
avec une addiction particulière à
l'alcool elle avait des problèmes avec
mais l'essentiel était le sirop contre
la toux le dx m
l'ingrédient actif du sirop contre la
toux c'est le dextro mais tu auras fans
entre il appelait ça le trip de robots à
cause du nom du médicament
le rebit us in ce qu'il faisait ses
boire quelques beautés du sirop et cela
lui donnait des hallucinations
c'est ce qui est recherché il s'est
drogué pendant 12 ans il avait des
règles très strictes qu'il formule est
comme ça pas de met pas deux héroïnes
on ne plaisante pas avec celle là on
croyait vraiment qu'il pouvait gérer ça
qu'il consommait correctement mais il
n'avait pas l'intention d'arrêter
oh
il croyait qu'il avait le contrôle oui
cet apple
oreilles
oui elle maintenant nous avons lydie la
petite elizabeth
elle est née le 6 novembre à 13h55
ce n'est pas mon premier enfant c'est le
premier enfant de cory mon premier
enfant a été adoptée ça a été mon choix
ma famille et moi avons décidé que
c'était la meilleure option et ma
cousine a fini par l'adopter
à l'époque c'était un gâchis vous savez
j'ai essayé de comprendre ce que c'était
d'arrêter la drogue et j'essayais de
devenir mère en même temps et ça ne
marchait pas du tout nous avons pour la
première fois rencontrer nos
protagonistes en juin 2019 et nous nous
sommes vus pour la dernière fois en
février 2020 le centre de
désintoxication ou travailler robe
rowling a été fermée entre temps quant à
rob il a rechuté et a recommencé à se
droguer
ensuite il a suivi un traitement d'un
mois dans une clinique et à trouver un
emploi
désormais il s'occupe de livraisons
d'appareils électroménagers
réfrigérateurs machines à laver
il se lève tous les matins à 5 heures il
vit principalement dans des hôtels parce
que son travail implique beaucoup de
déplacements il dit gagnait plus que
jamais et se sentir heureux et autonome
son rêve est d'économiser suffisamment
d'ici la fin de l'année pour louer un
bâtiment et faire sa propre maison de
sobriété pour qu'il puisse recommencer à
aider les autres le plus important c'est
de ne pas se perdre en essayant d'aider
les autres à se retrouver
l'épidémie est fier d'une incroyable
envergure prenez soin de vous avant de
vous occuper de quelqu'un d'autre
on ne peut aider personne si on ne gère
pas sa propre vie on ne peut pas
partager quelque chose qu'on a pas je
vivais dans une maison avec 14 gars et
chaque fois que je touchais le font
chaque fois que j'allais mal chaque fois
que je ressentais de la douleur j'allais
trouver l'un des gars dans la maison ai
demandé si je pouvais faire quelque
chose pour lui parce qu'on se sent
soulagé quand on est quelqu'un d'autre
le problème est que vous ne pouvez pas
utiliser ça comme un substitut
quand je sentais que c'était dur de
tenir au lieu d'aller me défoncer je
cherchais quelqu'un aider mais ça ne
change pas grand chose si on ne règle
pas le problème et le problème c'est moi
c'est comme si on mettait un pansement
dessus parce que quand 100 120 c'est
comme avec la drogue
on se sent mal pour moi ces gars étaient
donc un substitut à la drogue
en fait dans ma tête j'avais déjà
rechuté la rechute c'est tout un
processus
cela commence avec une idée puis vient
l'émotion et au moment où vous arrivez à
la partie physique il ne reste qu'à se
faire une piqûre
seulement 7% des toxicomanes arrive à
s'en sortir
oui un héroïnomane rechute en moyenne
huit fois s'ils ne meurent pas si on
compte tous les centres de traitement où
je suis allé à partir du moment où j'ai
pris mon chemin vers la guérison
puis la rechute la réhabilitation encore
une rechute etc
j'ai passé près de trois ans à suivre
des programmes et c'est sans compter le
temps où g était clean
mais à chaque fois que j'y allais
j'essayais de semer une graine d'espoir
j'ai fait des connexions ça n'a pas été
en vain parce que je suis là je suis en
vie et j'ai de la communauté pour
laquelle j'ai été un fardeau
l'oea a terminé ses études à l'académie
de coach on désintoxication créé par
reinhardt
en mai 2000 20 cela faisait deux ans
qu'elle avait cessé de se droguer
il ya plus de dix ans elle est allée à
l'université pour devenir travailleuse
sociale
aujourd'hui les avait utilisé ses
connaissances et son expérience pour
aider les toxicomanes a brisé leur
cercle vicieux et changer de vie
ils ont tort de croire que la rue
prendra soin d'eux qu'il y a des gens
dans la rue qui vont les soutenir mais
on peut les aider ici on peut leur faire
entrevoir une vie meilleure
doucement et oui ça prend du temps
peut-être qu'ils auront cette vie en fin
de compte ou pas ce qui est le plus
triste c'est qu'on voit des gens mourir
on voit des gens se suicider alexa cole
grove a terminé ses études pour être
coach mais elle n'a pas encore commencé
à travailler
elle veut d'abord mettre de l'ordre dans
sa vie et accorde toute son attention
aux enfants
j'ai eu quatre enfants de trois pères
différents
le père de ma première fille s'est pendu
le père des deux autres enfants
dallas et colton qui ont 5 et 4 ans est
un alcoolique il ne boit pas en ce
moment
mais le père de mon cadet toujours
toxicomanes donc il y a des chances
qu'un de mes quatre enfants deviennent
toxicomanes mais si je vis correctement
et leur montre comment il faut vivre ou
le de leur dire comment vivre ma mission
sera accomplie
je ne peux que montrer l'exemple et
s'ils choisissent la voie opposée ce
n'est pas grave je serai là pour eux je
ne les autoriserait pas à faire ça mais
je serai là pour eux quelques nouvelles
pour commencer avez vous suivi ce qui se
passe dans le comté de franklin cette
semaine
28 morts en dix jours encore une fois
c'est 28 morts dans un comté en l'espace
de dix jours
reinhardt continue de s'occuper de la
réhabilitation d'anciens toxicomanes et
d'éduquer les autres il croit que
l'entraînement individuel est le moyen
le plus efficace d'aider les toxicomanes
avec d'autres enseignants de l'académie
il considère la diction comme une
maladie mais ce n'est pas seulement une
maladie mentale et physique
c'est une maladie de l'esprit et c'est
ce qui empêche de nombreuses personnes
qui cherchent à s'en sortir d'y arriver
elle n'y croit pas assez n'ont pas
d'objectifs plus élevé ni la conviction
que ses objectifs peuvent être atteints
encore une fois je pense qu'il est
important de noter qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une épidémie d'opioïdes cette épidémie
est peut-être finalement une maladie de
l'esprit nous sommes devenus tellement
déconnecté tellement dépourvu d'esprit
de communautés en allant de l'avant
beaucoup d'entre vous travailleront dans
des conditions diverses et difficiles
mais sachez s'il vous plaît que vous
êtes le partie émergée de l'esprit de
cette révolution du retour à la vie